thanks Jen with the chief curator of the
World Chess Hall of Fame Shannon belly
thanks for joining us on the show now
the World Chess Hall of Fame does so
much that you have exhibitions you have
shows there's always something happening
over there tell us you have three
exhibitions right now first of all I saw
the world war two exhibition I thought
was amazing please tell everyone about
that one sure let's battle on the board
chest during World War two it was
curated by Emily Allred who is our
assistant curator and she had some help
with from john donaldson and it looks at
how chess was used during World War two
kind of as therapy for soldiers and how
different prisoners would make their own
chestnuts it's really a moving show
pretty incredible that during war you
could be playing chess and being
thorough having that therapy and a lot
of lot of without of soldiers that
injured during the war and we're able to
use their these chess sets which I know
there's some interesting stories behind
that one there are in like even the Red
Cross would give them out like it was
part of their rations packets in
prisoner of war camps pretty incredible
so tell us now there's a there's one
ivory chess sets that from the John
chrome Miller collection is called
encore and he'll be here this weekend
giving a lecture about that he'll be
here with the chest collectors
international group which is having
their annual conference here in st.
Louis to coincide with the sink filled
cup which will be great and you're
looking at some of the images of his
sets and some pieces from our first
floor show which is marcel dzama
mischief makes a move so tell us more
about this this latest one this yeah
third one you just mentioned this that
just look spectacular some of these
image great artists out of New York he's
actually from Canada from Winnipeg but
he is obsessed with Marcel Duchamp and
incorporates a lot of chess imagery into
his work so the whole show is centered
on a video project that he did for the
Toronto Film Festival a couple years ago
it stars Kim Gordon from Sonic Youth and
then there is a lot of supporting
artwork around it different like
beautiful sculptures and chess sets that
he created all for it how do you guys
make decisions and what you're going to
show I mean you've had
such a great variety of exhibitions that
have been over there what what attracts
you and it makes you decide well this is
where this is direction we're going to
go and I know you had the hip hop chassé
exhibit at one point is Bobby Fischer
yeah is over there what makes you well
our mission is really broad and that it
we kind of boil it down is that we want
to make chest fun and accessible and so
we this is already fun in excess to the
people that don't know and so we we
really hit chess history hard for sure
you know we celebrate the Hall of Famers
we do really intense chess history shows
but then we want to kind of bring in an
art crowd and bring in a general
interest crowd and you know our we've
had almost 50,000 people come since we
opened up we haven't even been open for
five years we've had people from many
countries every state in the United
States so we try to kind of look at
something to be like like one of our
things is like I never knew that or I
didn't know chess was related to that
and that happened a lot during our hip
hop show which was incredible that was
incredible i saw that one one of the
cooler ones who was the burning boards
yes which we did last year during the
same field cups that was with Glen
kynell and we had every sing field cup
participant play in that the
commentators got the only as well yes
with all of you and that was a chess
player playing maybe like somebody in
the arts field or somebody that wasn't a
strong chess player and it created this
nice not only just a beautiful setting
but a nice conversation I got to play
Leonard and that was really fun we were
playing with get burning burning candles
and tongs and the pieces you could even
recognizes work and they actually just
redid that a couple of months ago at
Brandeis University the Rose art museum
and I went up and participated in that
again it was really neat fantastic well
keep up the great work over the world
chess hall of fame yeah Shannon belly
chief curator at the world chess hall of
fame if you are if you do have a chance
to come down and visit the chess club
make sure you go across the street and
check out those incredible installations
they're quite a bit of fun